so welcome this guide is going to be on
gladiator and I'm going to be showing
you some beginner and advanced tips for
the character as well as some preferred
feats to use in 4v4 mode so let's get
right into this so first glance is
moveset seems kind of overwhelming with
a lot of moves but it's really not too
bad
gladiator has three basic combo groups
we'll call them the quad light the
double heavy and then multiple combos
that either consist of one two three or
four lights ending with a heavy at the
end of it the best ones in my personal
opinion are the light heavy nd light
light heavy combo because it's very hard
to land three or four lights in a row
unless the person doesn't know how to
block which is very rare
another important move in this move set
that's important is the skewer used in
Chains which is used by moving back and
pressing heavy when ending one of the
chains attacks we just talked about this
attack is unblockable move or gladiator
pierces the opponent with this trident
and can either hold it and gain some
bleed damage or press guard break to
throw them in any direction that he
chooses this can be used when you're a
wall other than that you can just hold
it and gain some glean damage because
throwing them not into a wall is kind of
useless although this is nice if done
enough times players will start to adapt
to this and then be able to carry it so
your next option is the Fusina ictus or
as anyway everyone calls it the toe stab
now do be aware there's a lot of Roman
ish words in this move setlist of this
whole video so if I get any of these
wrong please don't hate me in the
comments I'm sorry but basically moving
on
basically by moving back and guard
breaking you can stab your opponent for
further by leaving them open for other
teammates to attack or allowing you to
even the fight and reset it another
impressive combo you can pull off is any
one of the four chain attacks that are
displayed on screen and then when you
activate the unblockable heavy fainted
into the toe step allowing for some
interesting mix ups and confusing
opponents these other two groups of
combos are the crowd-pleaser and bee
sting
and the sucker punch and cheap shop
these will allow you to open up your
opponent because of the fast lights used
in crowd-pleaser and bee sting and the
stun ability used in cheap shot and
sucker punch these two also have a
chance to deal damage using the haymaker
feet but we'll discuss that later the
last few combos are situational but are
still definitely useful are the skewer
deflected and the counter jab and
counter jab heavy the skewer deflect if
you're feeling risky will apply bleed
damage to the target if landed just like
a normal V flex and since it's a skewer
meaning you can throw the opponent into
the wall to start another combo or stop
and hold it just for some bleed damage
just like the skewer ability used in the
chain attacks as for the counter jab
it's a parry punish which will only work
off Perry's just in case no one knew
that the counter jab with haymaker will
allow you to deal a bit of damage when
parrying and then you can use the
regular counter jab but only if you
don't have enough stamina to throw off
the last heavy attack and the counter
jab heavy or if you're in a dangerous
situation it's completely your call but
now that we're done with the moves let's
move on to the feet for the first slot I
found that iron lungs helps you if you
can't manage your stamina but if you
can't there but if you can deadly will
work as well to give you that slight
edge in a fight so the second feet
haymaker is your best bet allowing you
to deal more damage during your counter
jab counter jab heavy attacks as well as
sucker punch cheap shot and bamboozle
there's a lot of options for this one
that's why I feel that this one is the
best for the second feet to the third
feet this is completely up to your
choice as well as the fourth video is
completely up to your choice you have a
lot of option too if you prefer AoE
attacks then you might want to go with
the pongo mortis if you like single
target damage go for the trident and if
you want to be able to trap opponents to
start a combo easier go with the boar
lead or the bully door offs holy [ __ ]
I'm going to get flamed in the comments
for these names anyway for the last feet
and the 4th feet this is also your
choice as well if you prefer to use
feets in group fights then you can use
fear itself or the catapult whether you
want to do damage or debuff the enemy
it's up to you or if you're like me and
preferred to ride solo and just buffer
then go with roar of the crowd hope you
enjoyed this beginner and advanced guide
the gladiator hopefully didn't get too
complicated for you if you have any
questions of leave them in the comments
below and I'll answer them for you if
you like the video please sure to give
it a like subscribe if you're new and
hit that Bell right next dude so you
never miss one of my uploads like a
future got on the Highlander as well as
gameplay and streams so both of these
characters and with that guys I hope you
did enjoy and I'll see you later guys
peace out